emmanuel macron c'est quand même le
président de droite qu'on attendait pas
et il faut tout à fait sincère
personne n'a vu venir emmanuel macron
hommes se disait de gauche et qui depuis
qu'il est élu n'a fait que des mesures
que la droite préconise gauche ni droite
ni gauche
oui mais à la limite c'est pas lui si
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est pas lui de
le dire c'est à nous de constater les
faits et quand vous faites la liste de
toutes les réformes qu'il a initiées
depuis qu'il est élu c'est grosso modo
ce que la droite aurait dû faire quand
elle était au pouvoir
et je peux vous dire que ça fait du bien
pour notre pays après cinq années d'un
quinquennat désastreux celui de monsieur
hollande qui aussi bien sur le plan de
la politique économique et sociale que
sur le plan régaliens malheureusement
n'a pas fait les réformes qu'on
attendait et a fait plus tôt a pris
plutôt d'édition qui était mauvaise pour
le pays donc c'est incontestablement
aller dans le bon sens que de mener les
réformes que monsieur macron a commencé
de faire pour vous la meilleure réforme
non celle qu'il a menée on a goûté pour
moi la réforme qui était la plus
fondatrice c'était la réforme du code du
travail par ordonnance qui est
exactement que ce que je préconise
depuis des années donc je préfère
m'occuper pendant le programme je le dis
depuis des années il faut gouverner par
ordonnances sur un certain nombre de
sujets bon pour moi c'est la plus
emblématique où il ya aussi quelques
erreurs évidemment et dont certaines
très regrettable je pense que
l'augmentation de la csg technique était
une vraie erreur politique
vraiment idem d'ailleurs sur la décision
qui a été prise sur la pl pour être
maire de meaux c'est à dire une ville où
nous avons énormément de logements
sociaux est donc de locataires de ces
logements sociaux ça a été évidemment
une très mauvaise nouvelle et comme
toujours quand une décision est mauvaise
elle a pour conséquence une suite
enchaîne donc mauvaise décision et on a
planté il faut bien le dire les finances
de très nombreuses d'office d'achat
l'aise et ça c'est tout à fait
regrettable parce que ça veut dire qu'on
entretient - on a moins d'argent pour
entretenir les immeubles
voilà le genre de chose qui a des vrais
qu'on sait qu'ils ont des vraies
conséquences soient reportées à deux